make people an offer so good they feel
stupid saying no it changed my
perspective on how selling really worked
which is like you can learn to be
exceptional at sales or you can make an
incredible offer and it's a lot easier
to make an incredible offer than be
exceptional in sales it's like a hack
it's a shortcut to getting people to say
yes is try and find a way to put as much
value as humanly possible to actually
solve all their problems by making a
superior offer you become more
persuasive so you actually rely Less on
your Rapport building skills or like
your obstacle overcomes it's just like
make stuff people really want and
they'll buy it